[Music]
hello there February is here once again
and with it comes some of the biggest
games of the year I'm here to highlight
the ones worth your money and more
importantly the game's worth your time
from the AAA to the totally free to play
and everything in between today's video
is sponsored by IO interactive as the
Hitman Series has received a massive
update which changes everything we'll
talk about that very soon let's do this
Hogwarts Legacy arrives on February 10th
an open world single player RPG that
lets us attend the famous Wizarding
school and live life as a student there
but of course attending classes is only
one part of the adventure as we can
freely roam the grounds and surrounding
areas slowly piecing together the story
by the way if like me you haven't seen
the movies or read the books it's all
good Hogwarts Legacy is set 100 years or
so before Harry and the Gang attended
combat is based around spell casting and
has a cool gimmick where enemy Shields
can only be broken by the right type of
spell which is color-based so a purple
Shield will need a purple spell to break
you get the idea full touch the game's
previews arrived and are amazing this
honestly could be one of the games of
the year just keep in mind there is no
Co-op or multiplayer and to my surprise
there isn't a morality system either so
feel free to be as evil as possible and
not feel any repercussions I'm told I
should be Slytherin Hogwarts Legacy hits
PS5 Xbox series and PC on February 10th
and those on PS4 and Xbox One you'll be
able to play just not until April and
supposedly there's a switch version
coming mid-year
[Music]
next up like a dragon ishin basically
it's yet another Yakuza game but this
time the characters are taken back to
the times of the Samurai this is
actually a remake of a Japanese
exclusive PlayStation game from 2014 now
fully remade to Modern standards the
combat is part hack and slash part
timing focused and we'll be wielding a
standard samurai sword and a pistol and
straight up fists only brawling is
possible too by switching fighting
stances there are play styles to suit
everyone with the recent love of game
set in feudal Japan it'll be interesting
to see if we have another hit here like
a dragon ishian releases on February
21st on Playstation Xbox and PC
[Music]
have you heard the news Hitman 3 has
been rebranded as Hitman world of
assassination and now contains all 21
destinations from the trilogy all in one
place three games in one essentially and
here's a great piece of news for owners
of Hitman 3 you'll find the next time
you boot up you have been automatically
upgraded to the new updated content
totally free of charge Hitman asks us to
fill the boots of Agent 47 as he
Ventures the world taking out targets
all guns are blazing or with Sly and
cunning to make everything appear to be
an accident the Highlight for me in the
new update is the brand new game mode
exclusive to Hitman world of
assassination Agent 47 has set up his
own freelancer service we call the shots
we choose the assignments pick our
Loadout and choose a strategy yet in
this mode there are no game saves and
should we fail a contract every weapon
and item in our possession is lost along
with half our money too this change
makes every Mission intense as the
repercussions of failure can be
catastrophic we have optional objectives
to earn more money the risks are high
but the rewards are worth it Hitman has
become an amazing roguelike I have a
more in-depth video about the new
freelancer game mode coming later in the
week look out for it and for more
information about the game click the
link in the description below
there's 24 free to play games coming out
this year but for some reason right now
it's very slim pickings the only totally
free game I could find with no catches
this month is trackmania Ubisoft are
pushing trackmania as an esport right
now and to attract more players it's
time for the game to spread to other
platforms on February 2nd PC users on
Steam will be given access and then a
few weeks later we expect trackmania to
arrive on PlayStation and Xbox with a
comprehensive track editor Skin Creator
and replay function I can see why the
esport is growing and with the
introduction of weekly Nations leagues
it's actually possible to go pro doing
this console players keep your eye out
for trackmania towards the end of the
month
[Music]
Destiny 2 is a free-to-play game
available right now but it's DLCs cost
money to expand the game World this
month the latest DLC Lite 4 releases and
not to undersell this but players are
calling this Destiny's Infinity War
moment a new neon glowing world is here
and alongside that are new stories new
raids and a new subclass that lets
players harness neon light like a
grappling hook this will be Destiny's
biggest update ever as a new Guardian
ranking system arrives to let veterans
show off their Prestige but more
importantly let new players understand
the game with more ease I've tried
showing friends Destiny in the past and
they've all been too confused and
ultimately left this could fix that
issue and it has been hinted that
PlayStation Plus subscribers will start
receiving DLCs from the past for free as
the game evolves that definitely could
help lightfall drops on February 28th on
Playstation Xbox and PC
[Music]
so PlayStation VR 2 is here and a quick
note there are free game upgrades for a
few games you may already own Gran
Turismo 7 has a full psvr 2 mode totally
free to play same with Resident Evil
Village if you own the base game you now
own the full VR game too you can stand
near that big lady without any extra
cost there are a ton of new games
arriving for psvr 2 this month but I'll
just focus on one for now a full price
game Horizon call of the mountain we
play as a soldier who discovers a secret
about the robo animals and dinosaurs and
must save his clan from disaster we'll
see a low pop-up and lender hand but
it's up to us and our ball skill to win
this fight I know VR isn't for everyone
but check back later this month I'll be
playing psvr 2 on the channel
check out atomic heart a first person
shooter that tells of an alternative
history in which Russia won World War II
thanks to Advanced Robotics and then the
classic AI becomes sentient and decides
humans are the real threat in the world
combat in atomic heart is split between
typical gunfights and super powers like
freezing a robot mid-stride anybody else
getting Bioshock vibes from this this
could be something special it really
could February 21st on Playstation Xbox
and PC if this looks like your type of
game and now we have this move titled
wanted Dead a hack and slash slash
shooter we play as a member of the
zombie police force in Hong Kong over a
week in time just look at it it's
straight up filled with action and
packed with finishing moves each
playstyle has a dedicated skill tree to
upgrade as you dance around impossible
scenarios cutting off appendages freely
it just looks epic February 14th on
Playstation Xbox and PC
[Music]
and finally wild hearts a Monster
hunting game that could rival the other
monster hunter game but get this wild
Hearts has a building mechanic like
fortnite seriously attack from above by
quickly cranking 90s it goes further
than just Building height I've seen a
trebuchet I've seen a launch pad there
are many things you can build in Wild
Hearts angry beasts inhabit this land
and it's our job to slice them up to
save the world and more importantly look
awesome while doing it February 17th if
you're interested on Playstation PC and
Xbox so that's our month for what you're
playing this month I can't resist trying
Hogwarts but there's so many other games
to play who's gonna find the time I'm
Adam you're awesome it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
machine
[Music]